The Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom
is almost here and this video will catch
you up to speed on everything you need
to know before launch whether you're a
newcomer to the series or a long time
fan looking to see the latest
information in one place this ultimate
preview will cover everything from the
game's announcement all the way up to
the most recent news from Nintendo's
gameplay demonstration which showed us
our most detailed look yet at what we
can expect when tears of the Kingdom
releases this video will not contain any
spoilers from the leaked art book and
will only cover information that's been
officially released by Nintendo as well
as some theories and speculation based
on that information also I know this is
a lengthy video so chapter markers are
included below which means you can
instantly jump to any section you want
to hear more about first let's cover the
basics The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom will release exclusively for the
Nintendo switch on Friday May 12 2023.
Nintendo originally announced the game
with a first look teaser trailer back in
June of 2019. at the time no official
title was given and Nintendo simply
referred to it as the sequel equal to
the Legend of Zelda of breath of the
wild much of the title's development
remained shrouded in secrecy for nearly
two years from its announcement but at
E3 2021 Nintendo showed off gameplay for
the first time in the form of a new
teaser trailer which also included a
2022 release window in March of 2022
however Nintendo shared a development
update announcing the sequel would no
longer hit that Target but would instead
release in the spring of 2023. six
months later in September of 2022 the
first official trailer for the game
dropped complete with the final name The
Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom as
well as a new release date of May 12
2023 a second official trailer dropped
in February of 2023 and then a full-on
gameplay demonstration in March of 2023
which is when Nintendo announced
development was complete and that the
title would in fact hit its May 12th
release date we'll take a look at all of
these trailers in more detail later in
this preview tears of the Kingdom marks
the 20th entry in The Legend of Zelda
series it's being developed internally
at Nintendo by the epd the production
group number three which is the studio
dedicated solely to The Legend of Zelda
series the team started work on the
project in 2017 after completing
production on breath of the wild
longtime producer AJ alnuma is once
again at the helm for this title alnuma
worked as the Director and dungeon
designer from 1998's The Legend of Zelda
Ocarina of Time and he's remained
heavily involved with the series ever
since releasing a direct sequel with the
same overall style as something Nintendo
has only done a handful of times
throughout the series's history the most
notable example is probably the Legend
of Zelda Majora's Mask which is a direct
sequel to Ocarina of Time anuma played a
major role in the development of
Majora's Mask which had a ridiculously
short development time breath of the
Wild released alongside the switch in
March of 2017 and while it's hard to
separate it from the incredibly
successful hybrid console it's important
to remember it was originally developed
as a title for the Nintendo Wii U in
addition to releasing on the switch
breath of the wild still released the
very same day on the Wii U despite the
poor sales of that system so even though
tears of the Kingdom has quite a few
similarities with breath of the wild
it's important to note this game has
been developed solely for the Nintendo
switch system despite that tears has
actually been in production even longer
than its predecessor by the time it
releases next month it will have been a
full six years since breath of the
Wild's 2017 debut after the initial
announcement that a sequel was in
development al-numa told Game Informer
that one of the reasons they wanted to
continue immediately after breath of the
wild was because he quote wanted to
revisit that Hyrule again and use that
world again while incorporating new
gameplay and new story close quote
initially they were thinking of DLC
ideas but eventually hit a point where
they felt they had way too many ideas
for a DLC tears has long been
anticipated by fans and was even
nominated three straight years for the
game awards most anticipated game and
two straight years for the golden
joystick Awards Most Wanted game it
ended up winning both Awards in 2022.
it's no surprise to see the buzz around
the title considering breath of the wild
is not only one of the highest reviewing
Zelda games of all time it's also the
best-selling title in the series at
somewhere around 30 million copies sold
a staggering number for any game but
even more so for a first party exclusive
and a launch title at that tears of the
Kingdom will be the first Nintendo
switch game to launch with a 70 price
point for the standard version of the
game there's also a 130 dollar
collector's edition which will include a
hard copy of the game a collectible pin
set steelbook icon art poster and an art
book additionally Nintendo is releasing
a special edition version of the switch
Pro Controller for tears of the
Kingdom's release as well as a tears of
the Kingdom carrying case and even
though the new title won't be releasing
alongside a new Switch Pro or switch 2
Nintendo is releasing a limited edition
OLED version of the console that
features two gold joy cons as well as
special art for the back of the switch
system and the consoles dock it's
important to note this system does not
include a copy of the game a new link
amiibo for tears of the kingdom is also
on the way set to release the same day
as the game Nintendo has confirmed
in-game amiibo functionality scanning
the figure will grant players weapons
materials and a special fabric for
Link's paraglider they also mentioned
scanning other amiibo from The Legend of
Zelda series but don't specifically
outline which ones or if all of them
will be supported in tears of the
kingdom when it comes to the game's
story Nintendo has kept many details
hidden as they so often do across all of
the various trailers though fans have
been able to piece together some details
in addition to making quite a few
educated guesses about where things
could be heading in the sequel but first
let's cover the information revealed
directly from Nintendo that doesn't
require any speculation or Theory
crafting we know the title is a direct
sequel to breath of the wild and will
feature the same Zelda and Link we got
to know in the first game at least
presumably I think it's a pretty safe
bet the game takes place after the
events in breath of the wild but with
the series's history of traveling
through time and even other dimensions
it's hard to say for certain if
everything we do will take place
chronologically after breath of the wild
the first look trailer so Zelda and Link
making their way through some sort of
cave toward what appears to be Ganon and
is being held in place by this
mysterious hand the trailer focuses
heavily on two opposing elements forces
the first being this green effect we see
with the hand here and then the red
effect here which should be familiar to
fans of the first game the red
represents the corruption of Calamity
Ganon and this force was seen on many
occasions throughout breath of the wild
the events of breath of the wild really
kick off thanks to a prophecy that
foretold the return of Calamity Ganon
the hylians took this prophecy seriously
and decided to search for the
resurrection site as they were doing so
they Unearthed four massive mechanical
beasts that could be used to stop
Calamity Ganon they chose four Pilots as
Champions to assist Zelda and Link in
sealing Ganon away unfortunately for the
Champions Gannon knew of the prophecy
and took control of the Guardians and
divine beasts killing the Champions and
wounding Link in the process and so
Zelda remained alone doing battle
against Ganon and waiting for Link's
return when he finally wakes up in the
shrine of Resurrection 100 years had
passed since Ganon defeated the
Champions unfortunately his injury
resulted in memory loss and it's only
through the course of the game that link
will slowly regain these fragmented bits
of his memory link freeze each of the
Divine beasts from ganon's Calamity as
well as each of the four Guardian
Spirits he also retrieves the master
sword which Zelda had hidden away for
safe keeping years earlier with the
master sword in hand and all of the
Divine beasts free link finally rejoins
Zelda and the two are able to seal
Calamity Ganon away at least until
whatever is going on here in tears of
the Kingdom link Zelda and Ganon all
appear set to return here in the sequel
and despite much speculation over the
years about playing as Zelda or even
Ganon what we've seen so far points only
to link surprisingly we've only seen a
handful of other characters pop up in
the trailer so far there's a korok
wearing a backpack here saying he needs
to find his friend and we catch a brief
Glimpse at Beetle here at the dueling
Peak stable he served as a merchant in
breath of the wild and will likely serve
a similar role in the new game there's
also a non-hostile character labeled as
a ranger construct that players can talk
to although we have yet to see the
dialogue or what their role may be in
the game now while we know at least a
little bit about Calamity from the first
game it's the green force that has fans
speculating the most in the the short
First Look trailer we saw a quick shot
of the green arm appearing to overtake
Link's right hand we see a quick shot of
the Calamity spreading and also what
seems to be Link and Zelda reaching for
one another the Calamity finally reaches
Ganon and appears to resurrect him at
least in some form and then Hyrule
Castle appears to be overtaken by the
Calamity as well breaking and even
rising up into the sky the teaser
trailer in 2021 would give us a bit more
with these two opposing forces we see
more of the red Calamity and a very
quick flash of Link's right arm that's
actually getting pulled into the
corruption there's another quick shot of
Calamity Ganon appearing very much alive
and even Zelda falling into a pit of
Darkness the trailer then cuts to link
falling from the skies in completely
different clothing and a right arm
that's been altered presumably by
whatever happened underneath Hyrule
castle with Zelda and Ganon but goblins
are back once again and we see yet
another shot of Hyrule Castle rising
from the earth surrounded by Calamity
the delayed trailer in March of 2022 was
mostly about the release window shifting
but we also saw a brief Glimpse at a
clip that could have a major impact on
both the story and gameplay in tears of
the Kingdom alnuma also mentioned that
the game would not only take place on
the ground in the sequel but in the
skies above as well we see Link in those
tattered clothes once again and another
look at his right arm but most
importantly we see him holding what
appears to be a broken Master Sword one
of the most interesting details to
consider here is actually the logo for
tears of the Kingdom because the sword
itself is featured in the logo for the
game at least part of it is obviously
the sword is an iconic item from the
franchise and will almost certainly play
a key role in the game but what I'm most
interested in is how we can see this
mysterious green force appearing to
actually complete the broken section of
the Master Sword to be fair this could
totally just be a fun little logo design
trick that the designers thought looked
great and I have to agree it looks
fantastic but I think we have to
seriously consider the possibility that
this could very well be hinting at a
story element from the game such as the
possibility that we'll need to use the
green force to somehow repair the master
sword the next trailer which Nintendo
calls trailer number one starts with a
focus on these mysterious glyphs plenty
of fans speculating about who they could
be depicting what's clear in this shot
is that there appears to be a great
battle occurring with one side
surrounded by the force of Calamity and
an opposing Force without any Calamity
around them this is also the trailer
where Nintendo confirmed the name as
tears of the Kingdom it's also important
to note they clarified that tears is the
correct pronunciation and it's not meant
to be tears as it was originally unclear
to which they were referring to with the
title tears have appeared in the series
before in the form of sacred Tears In
The Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword these
tiers are located in the Silent Realm of
the Faron Woods Elven volcano leneiru
desert and skyloft in that game the
tears would halt the movement of
Guardians for 90 seconds and you needed
to collect all 15 to pass each trial it
remains to be seen If Tears will return
as an item in this installment of the
series but one thing's for sure everyone
has noted the overall darker tone in
many of these trailers with some even
speculating that tears of the Kingdom
could represent the definitive end of
this Zelda Timeline yet another trailer
this one named trailer number two gave
us even more insight into the story with
multiple lines of dialogue this time
starting with this one rise rise my
servants
sweep over Hyrule eliminate this Kingdom
and her allies
leave no survivors
many believe this voice belongs to Ganon
himself the trailer shows even more
Calamity spreading in Rage but goblins
and plenty of other enemies and even
another shot of Ganon with the Calamity
taking hold of him perhaps this battle
that we're seeing is actually the one we
saw depicted in the trailer before but
the Sinister voice is not the only one
we hear in the trailer but link I am not
sure you'll be able to stop him wherever
we find ourselves at the start of Tears
of the kingdom it appears that Gannon
seizes the upper hand fairly early on
and at this point Zelda is recognizing
the severity of the situation but the
most mysterious line actually comes near
the end of the trailer when we hear
Zelda again please lend him your power
who could Zelda be speaking to here she
is clearly issuing a plea for someone or
something to lend us their power it's
possible she's speaking to the source of
that mysterious green force that we've
seen throughout the trailers to this
point and the very same force that
appears to be powering Link's new right
arm and that leads us to the zonai Die
Hard fans are probably surprised we've
made it this far into the video without
yet mentioning The Zone eye you may
remember a bit about them if you played
the first game but to summarize they're
a mysterious race that left behind
structures in breath of the wild and
according to that game they appear to
have vanished a long time ago the zonai
ruins in breath of the wild actually
stretch all the way from the demel
forest to the spring of courage and
Faron the the barbarian set armor is
gifted by monks that link finds inside
the three vast mazes in breath of the
wild and is believed these mazes relate
back to the zonai and many fans have
also speculated that this green effect
is at least somehow related back to the
zonai now it's not all just speculation
the zonai have in fact been confirmed to
feature at least somewhat we don't know
how prominently but they are for sure
playing a role in tears of the Kingdom
thanks to our final official reveal from
Nintendo which came in the form of a
gameplay demo this gameplay
demonstration focused primarily on
Link's new abilities which we'll touch
on here shortly but in doing so they
also reveal two creatures that are at
least somehow connected to the zonai the
first a construct enemy here which
appears on one of the sky islands and
attacks the player we see that green
energy again here and it almost appears
to be powering this enemy perhaps more
interestingly we come across another of
these constructs this one labeled as a
ranger construct but this one is on the
surface not in one of the sky islands
and it also doesn't appear to be hostile
at all toward link now how do we know
that these are related to the zonai well
it's because they actually drop an item
when defeated called a zonai charge at
least the Hostile one does and when we
defeat that construct enemy notice it
doesn't explode in the calamity-like
energy as the picoblins do instead it's
the green and blue energy now overall
with the story there have been some
strong hints even from alnuma himself
that the story of Tears of the Kingdom
could be darker than Majora's Mask which
is widely recognized as one of the
darkest entries in the series now as it
relates to the story we should also
point out what we haven't seen first we
don't see any of the shrines from the
first game but we do see similar size
structures with that mysterious green
force swirling around them some fans
think that that could be tears of the
Kingdom's Shrine equivalent the large
chica Towers from breath of the wild are
noticeably different here and they don't
match up with the previous locations
there also isn't any sign of the massive
Divine Beast Machines that played such
an important role in the first game oh
and remember those Guardians that just
chase you around the whole game no sign
of them either and then there's the
Chica slate which we haven't seen at all
despite the fact that it was such a core
part of the gameplay in the first game
instead this time it seems Link's
special ability abilities are controlled
by his altered right arm when it comes
to tears of the Kingdom's gameplay it
makes the most sense if we start with
the first game as it looks like many
gameplay elements will carry over link
can still run jump climb and glide
weapons still degrade over time cooking
makes a return and the minimap still
includes temperature weather and sound
gauges tears of the kingdom is also
confirmed to take place in the very same
Hyrule as breath of the wild this
actually marks the first time in the
history of the series that we've
returned to the same Hyrule as a
previous game unless of course you count
like Link Between Worlds which use the
same Hyrule as linked to the past now
when we combine this with the fact that
al-numa said Nintendo had so many ideas
for a breath of the wild DLC that they
couldn't fit into an actual DLC we
actually start to touch on one of the
issues that fans have brought up with
the footage and details that have been
revealed so far about tears of the
kingdom and that's that it's just too
similar to its predecessor but on the
flip side Nintendo has stated tears of
the kingdom is its own game and the
recent gameplay reveal showed off quite
a few differences both in the gameplay
and in the landscape when compared to
the first game in fact the recent game
gameplay demo focused almost solely on
showing off four of Link's new abilities
and the many ways that they're going to
affect gameplay those abilities are
recall fuse Ultra hand and Ascend all
four of them are controlled with Link's
right arm and are somehow powered by
that green force they each have their
own corresponding icon and can be
activated with the L shoulder button
recall is an ability that allows link to
reverse the path of a moving object we
saw him use this ability in combat on
the spike rolling down the hill here in
one of the previous trailers the
gameplay demo showed recall being used
more as a traversal mechanic link can
use it on the large stone block that's
falling from the sky here and this is
one way to reach the sky islands
apparently though this is just one of
the many ways that we'll be able to
reach them there are these rails that we
know link can ride on we see that in
another trailer perhaps this is another
way that we'll travel up to these Sky
Islands as well and is it just me or did
Nintendo specifically choose to focus
the camera on this Dragon just as they
mentioned other ways to reach Sky
Islands I don't know dude flying a
dragon would be pretty awesome the
second ability is fuse while weapons
will still break fuse enables players to
combine two objects to make a weapon
both more powerful and more durable
Nintendo showed several different use
cases for fuse the First with a tree
branch and a rock which combined
together to form a makeshift Hammer then
they showed link fusing a long stick to
a pitchfork which creates a weapon that
can attack from even further away fuse
doesn't only apply to Link's melee
weapons though he can also fuse items to
arrows such as a white choo choo jelly
which makes it an ice Arrow you can even
fuse case eyeballs to create an arrow
that will now home in on its Target we
also see them fuse a puff shroom to
Link's Shield which results in a collab
of smoke whenever it's struck by an
enemy and while we don't know how this
will work exactly the gameplay did
confirm that enemies we encounter can
also have fused weapons knowing how many
items were in breath of the wild it
seems like a pretty safe bet to say that
what we've seen so far with fuse is only
scratching the surface of the many
different variations you can come up
with in tears of the Kingdom there are
sure to be a ridiculous number of
customization options for fuse in the
final game this seemingly unlimited
potential applies to the next stability
Nintendo showcased as well Ultra hand
with this players can essentially glue
different objects from the world
together to make their own Creations to
help them overcome obstacles and
challenges in the demo link glues logs
together to form a raft he uses Ultra
hand again to add two powered fans which
are activated by striking them once
they're in place and aligned in the
right position they'll power the raft
across the river notice there is a
single battery indicator when the fans
are running it does appear to refill on
its own after a cool down period fans
have speculated that the green vials on
Link's belt could possibly act as some
sort of Wireless source of energy for
items that require this battery power
Nintendo didn't comment on them in the
demo but the midi map did show some new
icons we haven't seen before and one of
them happens to be a battery icon
perhaps that's a location where link
could find another vial to add to his
belt which could in turn add an
additional battery to power certain
machines even longer before they need to
recharge after all we've seen these
flying vehicles that are far more
advanced than the raft they made in the
gameplay demo they're even flying
Creations like this one and in order for
this one to fly very high it would
certainly need to have more than one
battery to power it you can see here it
just barely lifts off the ground with
one they even confirmed that the ultra
hand ability is how we'll create the
vehicles we've seen so far in other
trailers and we know we'll be able to
use these vehicles to travel by land air
or water the final ability they touched
on is Ascend if you're in a location
with a ceiling you can use Ascend to
travel up and through the floor above
they show the ability a second time
inside a cave that has a hill above it
of course you'll still be able to climb
using your stamina if you choose but
Ascend seems like it will be a quick way
to reach the top of structures so long
as there's a ceiling and floor above and
while they didn't show this one they did
mention that if you ever find yourself
stuck in a cage with a ceiling that you
can use Ascend to get out seems like an
oddly specific example there if you ask
me maybe a little tease of something to
come later in the game breath of the
wild focused heavily on overcoming the
environment much more so than any Zelda
game before it and overall it appears
Nintendo is certainly doubling down on
that sandbox style formula that played a
key role in making the first game such
an incredible success they want you to
explore the world and overcome its many
obstacles not by simply picking up and
using the tools they provided but also
by using your imagination and creativity
to test the limits of those tools and
what they can do inside the world around
you it remains to be seen if Nintendo is
bringing back any gameplay elements
inspired by non-breath of the wild Zelda
titles such as traditional dungeons a
long time staple of the series and much
requested addition for tears of the
Kingdom as for locations we know the
game takes place in the same high role
as breath of the wild and many of the
locations we know from the game should
return here but possibly with a Twist in
a different state or maybe even
inhabited by different groups of people
or enemies the most notable new addition
are the sky islands there's evidence
that points to these being related to
the zonai such as the stone dragon heads
that look similar to the ones found in
the zonai ruins back in breath of the
wild the yellow trees and vegetation
seen in the gameplay demo are also very
different from what we've seen
throughout the rest of Hyrule the sky
islands are seen all over the world in
the gameplay that we've seen so far and
it appears they can vary in both size
and how far they are from the ground
which could explain why the minimap now
displays altitude in addition to
latitude and longitude we've seen plenty
of familiar enemies as well that are set
to make a return including both moblins
and the Goblins the stone Talos which
appears to have a new variant with an
enemy fort on top of it lizalfos high
noxes boss blinds and a soldier
construct which is the enemy we talked
about earlier and likely connected to
the zonai as for some other new enemies
there's a flying creature that has the
ability to transport bakoblins as well
as a zombie-like enemy that's almost
certain to Mark the return of re-deads
which have long been one of the most
terrifying enemies in the series there's
also a massive Golem enemy that's made
up by many of these Stone cubes and then
there's the dragon that's been clearly
visible in the trailers at least from
afar swords Shields bows arrows and many
of the consumable items from breath of
the wild will make a return here
Nintendo has already shown us a few ways
that these familiar items can be used
for different effects and tears of the
Kingdom specifically with the fuse
ability food rupees heart containers and
the stamina gauge are also back the
chica a slate appears to be out and at
least somewhat replaced by Link's new
arm and then there are the green vials
on Link's belt which we can only
speculate on at this point the gameplay
demo also showed the Puffs room zonai
charge Soldier construct horn korok
frond and a stem bulb and with that new
fuse ability there are sure to be a
ridiculous amount of new items that
players will be able to craft on their
own The Legend of Zelda tears the
kingdom will for sure be one of the
biggest titles of 2023 but even with
everything we've seen so far there are
some concerns fans have actually share
some of these concerns even though I'm
still really looking forward to the game
a lot of these stem from the fact that
the game is taking place in the same
Hyrule as before one many players have
already explored in great detail and
despite the well-received critical and
Commercial Success of breath of the wild
there are plenty of vocal fans who were
hoping to see more of a return to the
style of previous Zelda games there's
also the reality that the game was
originally rooted in DLC ideas rather
than a totally new Sequel and it is in
fact releasing on the AG Nintendo switch
Hardware that is significantly
underpowered compared to Modern PCS the
PS5 and the Xbox his ex if you'd like to
hear more about those concerns then
check out the video on the right side of
your screen next also big shout out to
all of our channel members of house
wreck and tour thank you so much for
your continued support here on the
channel and guys if you aren't a member
yet you can read all about the benefits
by clicking on the community tab below
as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon